[Music]
how will you try to describe what may be
the strategic vision of the new
administration to this extent you can
see anyone the leadership right now is
not cohesive
it's a strange amalgam of variable
senior experienced officers plus some
eccentric deviations from that standard
on the part of one or two but that will
probably become increasingly evident and
will probably be resolved by dismissal
and gradually the leadership will begin
to be more cohesive I think in effect
the administration will have to go
through a process of maturation which
matches the needed process of maturation
of the American people it speeds to be
identified with the ending of specific
Wars what is the ultimate goal of peds
to establish and maintain a structure of
international order a final word all of
the above is likely to be complicated by
the increasing probability that severe
weather problems on a global scale
will intensify political problems global
warming is already beginning to impact
more ominously signaling prospects of
extensive meltdowns and the resulting
threats to some existing habitations
cumulatively that could generate greater
public anxiety that strategic and
security is now a fact of life on a
scale heretofore not experienced by the
now increasingly vulnerable humanity
regional cooperation would thus require
shared wisdom
and political will to work together
despite his star conflicts and the
continued presence of nuclear weapons
always potentially devastating but even
after 70 years still unlikely to result
in a one-sided victory
[Music]